Nathaniel Philbrick author of sea of
glory
America's voyage of discovery the u.s.
exploring expedition 1838 to 1842 what
is this book about it's about the
greatest voyage most people have never
heard of
it's an expedition launched by the US
government to do what James Cook had
done for for England and other European
explorers to take America to the world
the plant the flag in the world explore
the islands that no one had any charts
for to it go where literally no man had
ever gone before
who's James Cook James Cook was the
Paramount British explorer of the 18th
century that had opened up the Pacific
discovering islands at every turn and he
had had team of scientists with him and
he this is a function of the
Enlightenment and he opened up a whole
new era of exploration in the name of
science but also in the name of empire
so this voyage started on what date how
many ships how many men and briefly
where did they go yeah well it began
August 18 1838 left the Norfolk Navy
Yard six vessels 346 men making it one
of the largest voyages of discovery in
the Western world I mean this was a huge
undertaking for a small a big country
but with a small Navy and they were to
go around the world they would
eventually cover 87,000 miles crisscross
the Pacific and venture down to really
know down to the bottom of the world
towards Antarctica where no one really
knew it was down there what was the
purpose of it and who paid for it was
paid for by the US government and one of
the primary functions was to chart
Pacific Islands that no one had any
charts for it at this point people like
the Nantucket whalers were going to
places that not even cook had been to
the Fiji group for example there are no
reliable charts of that and so this was
a government-sponsored expedition to
survey chart these islands this this
expedition would chart 280 Pacific
Islands creating a hundred and eighty
charts and would really reinvent
navigation in the Pacific how long were
they gone for years for which was a year
longer than they expected
and so that some of these young guys
were midship and the neh
eighteen years old would come back be 22
year old men they left what you said was
six ships how many did they come back
with they came back with three of them
they would lose this one would be sent
back the store ship relief was so slow
that the commander sent it back fairly
early in the voyage but they would lose
two vessels one a small schooner would
be lost in a storm off Cape Horn the
other would be the peacock the
sloop-of-war 118 feet would be wrecked
on the mouth of the Columbia River here
is a you tell me what it is it's not a
photograph what is yeah it's it's a
modern rendering of the u.s. exploring
expedition by Mark Meyer a noted British
maritime artist and it's showing the
squadron the six vessels an orange Bay
which is very near Cape Horn and this
was before they were about to head down
south one of two sails south to try to
identify what was beneath the Antarctic
Circle which one of these is the
Vincennes
the Vincennes is the large one on the
left with with no sails up the Vincennes
was the flagship the the commander
Charles Wilkes was on the Vincennes and
the Vincennes was one of the favorite
ships than at US Navy at this time she
was B me but she was very fast and this
was would be her third trip around the
world how big would she have been
hundreds inity and so not a huge naval
vessel by any means but big enough to
command a lot of respect when it pulled
into a little coral atoll in the middle
of the Pacific how many men would she
carry she would carry close to two
hundred two hundred men and what made
this squadron unique is that in addition
to naval officers and sailors there were
scientists there were artists this was
before photography so that there are
people constantly making sketches and
charts of what was going on there were
taxidermist there were people there to
repair the scientific instruments that
were brought along which one on this
these two pages in your book is the
smallest vessel on how big was she
yeah the two schooners which are on the
upper left
they were both of them were about the
same size Segal and the flying fish
around 70 feet they had been New York
pilot boats before they became naval
vessels and so they were transformed
into exploring vessels and set out
around the world with these much larger
ships how long were they again and just
a little over 70 feet and how many
people were on a 15 15 men with a
complement of about three officers and
so it was not much when you're rounding
Cape Horn to being something that small
in 1838 what were the politics of the
country who was president and is it was
there a figure of how much money was
spent yeah there was an initial funding
of a hundred and fifty thousand to get
things going but more would would go
through and that was a lot of money back
then and this had been started by the
the Andrew Jackson's administration but
it had taken two years to get this going
and it would be the martin van buren
administration that would finally get
the expedition launched in 1838 and the
leader Charles Wilkes was an ardent
Jacksonian Democrat and definitely
political connections had something to
do with the fact that he was named
leader of this expedition in 1838 when
this voyage began how much of this had
the United States already done how many
expeditions like this I mean there was
really X global exploration was nil when
it came to America at this point there
had been the Lewis and Clark expedition
that had left in 1803 and that had been
called a voyage of discovery because
they were looking for a waterway from
the Mississippi to the Pacific but after
that there was some very random attempts
at exploration in the interior of the
country this would be the u.s. exploring
expedition of 1838 was a whole new era
the America's first attempt to go at it
head-to-head with the European powers
that were launched on this real
international rivalry to discover and
explore the last unknown portions of the
planet
you've mentioned Charles Wilkes several
times he's obviously an important part
of this book and here's the picture of
him it's a painting when was this done
this was done soon after he returned
from the expedition in 1842
and when the expedition left in 1838 he
was a 40-year old lieutenant who had
spent most of his naval career on land
he had been head of the depot of charts
and instruments on Capitol Hill where he
worked out of his home to brick
buildings that had been originally built
by George Washington this boarding
houses and there he had built an
observatory and it's it would not later
evolve into the Naval Observatory but
that's where Charles Wilkes was and he
he he had a scientific background
not much of a seamanship background and
he had the political connections to get
the the appointment what was his rank
and I know you know that the rank is a
story that goes all the way through the
book yeah rank was very important to
Wilkes and it should have been really he
was a lieutenant and this is it this is
the peacetime Navy and so there was you
know people were in line waiting to
become captains and Wilkes was a fairly
old lieutenant but that's what people
were then and he he was in charge of
this huge expedition he would he had 30
or some lieutenants he was to command
and to command them he needed to outrank
them and he was under the impression
that the Secretary of the Navy was going
to give him an acting appointment as
captain and he really deserved it to
lead something sighs he really needed to
have that appointment but he his appoint
was so controversial
the Navy hierarchy was outraged that the
Secretary of the Navy basically wimped
out and in the last minute did not give
him his acting appointment to captain
and this would burn in at Wilkes his
soul and I think really pointed to a
level of insecurity at the beginning
that would make it very difficult for
Wilkes to command this expedition did
they all know where they were going from
the beginning
yeah the Wilkes had written out a fairly
detailed description of where they would
go that was then approved by the
Secretary of the Navy and it would be
pretty close to where they would would
go it was it was way it was too
ambitious the way it was a typical
American operation ambitious underfunded
and
making it up as it went along and the
remarkable thing is how much of the of
the to-do list they would accomplish go
through the basic places where they went
they headed out from Norfolk
they went to Madeira off the western
coast of Africa and they would search
out various navigational areas
throughout the Atlantic make their way
to Rio de Janeiro
where they reprovision and then they
went down to Cape Horn where they made
their first stab to the south they would
sail to the South Shetland Islands and
very close the Antarctic Peninsula they
would then head up to up the coast of
western coast of South America to Peru
and then head out into the Pacific they
would make their way across the Pacific
surveying and charting islands all the
way while the scientists collected
artifice specimens and artifacts they
would make their way to Sydney Australia
in December of 1839 they would then
leave from their sail directly south and
head to Antarctica and and come across
what they called the icy barrier head
west and surveying and charting the
coast of Antarctica they would then
return to New Zealand to the Fiji
Islands to the Pacific to Hawaii the
Pacific Northwest and then back the long
way to the Philippines to Singapore Cape
of Good Hope and home to New York for
years 87,000 miles how many men lost
their lives on the trip
close to 40 men died during this trip
which is is a pretty large figure but
when you consider how where they went
and the dangers they endured and and the
losses that similar exploring
expeditions had it wasn't that bad
really they would lose two ships though
and one of the schooners they would lose
all hands up in a storm yeah three men
on a pictures of them or rent artist
renderings on the page next to Charles
Wilkes one of them at the top is Charles
Erskine yeah Charlie your sky
yeah who is he he was a 16 year old
sailor a kid who had gotten to know
Wilkes prior to this expedition on a
very short surveying operation of
George's Bank and Charlie was a
beautiful boy as described by Wilkes
Charlie would make the mistake of taking
some time off to see his mother and when
they were in Boston and would get
whipped for returning to the ship late
and would develop a hatred of Wilkes and
would even think about trying to kill
Wilkes in the early stages of this
expedition would not and would go on to
learn teach himself how to read and
write during the expedition and late in
life would write an account of the u.s.
exploring expedition that tells the
story of the expedition from the
perspective of a common seaman which is
you tell a story where he was about to
drop something on Charles Wilkes his
head yes just a few weeks into the
expedition Charlie had been whipped by
Wilkes earlier on and and just had
developed this need to get his revenge
and it had been at night he was on the
deck of the vessel and it was his watch
and he could see what was midnight and
you can see that Wilkes through a
skylight could see Wilkes laboring over
a chart and Charlie took a blank in of
heavy metal cylinder and suspended it
over the skylight and was about to drop
it on wilks's head thinking it would
kill him when he saw a vision of his
mother and his mother said don't do it
Charlie Charlie relented Wilkes lived
and the expedition would go on who was
William Reynolds William Reynolds was a
22 year old past midshipman meaning that
he had passed an exam that would qualify
him to be eventually become a lieutenant
he was from Lancaster Pennsylvania and
he was an unusual naval officer he had
the heart and soul of a poet he loved to
read he loved to write and throughout
his naval career which had begun when he
was 16 kept personal journals that he
would share with his family back in
Lancaster and William Reynolds began
this expedition adoring Wilkes as most
of the young officers did because Wilkes
had gotten this great expedition off the
ground in the beginning but he ended up
hating Wilkes and Reynolds would keep a
journal a private Journal that Wilkes
would never see that would swell to
250,000 words it's now at Franklin
Marshall College and Lancaster and it's
just a credible document it tells the
secret story of what happened between
Wilkes and his
officers also is a coming-of-age story
in which this 22 year old kid becomes a
great writer because by the end of this
expedition he was writing at a level
that I would I would compare to Melville
to Dana I mean it's that good and
Reynolds wrote it all down and it was a
huge help for me and writing this book
is the actual journal still the journal
still at front yes yeah they are at
Franklin Marshall and actually will be
publishing a an edited version of
Reynolds journal in 2004 and it really
is a document that is very personal but
also tells the the the story of this
huge expedition in a way that is is
really important I think when it comes
to American see writing did all six of
these ships sail together at all times
at times they tried to particularly when
it came to surveying the islands they
would carefully coordinate their
activities around the islands two of the
vessels would take one side typically
two would take the other side of an
island and work their way around and
they could survey a typical 14 mile
coral at told three and a half hours I
mean they got it down that well but then
there were times when they would
purposely split up when they were in
Hawaii
Wilkes would send two of the vessels
into the Central Pacific where they
would chart the islands that would
figure so large in in World War two and
then when they went down into the
Antarctic they would inevitably have to
split out the Gaels that would rack the
the squadron would require them to to go
off in different direction how fast
today sail you know it depended but in a
going along at a good clip they could
get get up the Vincennes the flagship
could get up to eleven twelve knots how
often did they hit bad weather I
depended where they were and went in the
Antarctic there was bad weather almost
every day they weathered three different
gales dodging icebergs all the way the
Cape Horn similar time they just Gail
after Gail after Gail and then they
would you know go up to the Pacific
Northwest and there there were
challenges of a different sort it would
be cold wet a lot of the
but then the currents and and all the
navigational hazards up there made their
life a misery so it was constant hazards
they ever come close to losing a ship
entirely yeah off the Cape Horn they had
finished their first dab south and
Wilkes was trying to coordinate the
squadron to head up north to Valparaiso
and the one of the schooners was was
lingering there when they were hit by a
gale and it was they all it would be the
the seagull would be lost with all hands
apparently in this storm they they
thought her masts may have tripped up
torn up the deck but all all seventeen
men were lost ever did they ever find
anything no they sent later an
expedition from South America would be
sent down to look for them but they
never found anything you have another
rendering on this page man named William
Hudson correct how old was he in that Ed
caricature yeah that was done during the
expedition and he was in his early 40s
he was the second in command of the u.s.
exploring expedition he was a good
friend of Wilkes probably his best
friend in the Navy prior to this
expedition
but unfortunately Hudson although he was
a great seaman did not have any
surveying experience and this would
become a real burden to Wilkes as the
years of the expedition unfolded because
so much of this expedition involved
surveying and charting a very complex
operation particularly in sailing
vessels and Hudson could get the the
ships there but was not of not much help
when it came to the actual surveying how
did you get interested in all this in
the first place well for me it began
with my previous book in the heart of
the sea about a whaling voyage that went
very bad and what fascinated me about
whaling and particularly Nantucket
whalers I'm from Nantucket is that these
guys were not only the the greatest
whale killers the world has ever known
they were the some of the greatest
explorers and it was the this era of
global exploration not only
government-sponsored but part of the
whaling fleet China traders that
fascinated me and at the end of in the
heart of the
see the captain of the whaleship Essex
goes out one last time and comes across
a naval schooner off Peru and that one
of the officers on that schooner was
Charles Wilkes at 24 years old who would
fifteen years later lead the u.s.
exploring expedition into the Pacific
indeed you when you researched him then
as you say to yourself that's a book no
I didn't not at first I I had gotten
wilks's autobiography which is a heat
mammoth book that Wilkes wrote late in
his career in an attempt to to redeem
his his his legacy and in it he
describes his meeting with this this
whaling captain and I I was fascinated
by who he was I had heard about the u.s.
exploring expedition in fact I read a
little some of about it when I was
researching in the heart of the sea but
I didn't know that much about it and
then I began to realize look what all
the things these guys did why don't I
know anything about it so for me it
became kind of detective story this is
an extraordinary expedition something
that I was never taught in high school
or in college why not and and so that's
when I decided this is the next story
for me
where'd you grow up I grew up in the
Maritime center of the universe
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania but that we
would summer for a couple of weeks every
summer on Cape Cod where I developed a
real love of the sea what were your
parents doing then my parents are both
teachers my dad's a retired English
professor with a specialty in American
maritime literature and he was an at
Pitt at University of Pittsburgh so
that's why we were there and where did
you go to college I went to Brown
University studied what American
literature and was on the sailing team
and was was very much interested in the
American literature of the sea I took
some history courses but I was by no
means a budding historian in college
your first book was written when my
first book was a sailing book written
way back in 87
and we moved to Nantucket when I about
that time and I became interested in the
history of Nantucket moby-dick had been
my Bible and moving to Nantucket was a
real revelation and so I began
researching the history of the island
wrote two histories of Nantucket both
the whaling era and the Native American
side of things and then wrote in the
heart of the sea about the loss of the
whaleship Essex which was the basis for
the climax of Moby Dick again what year
in the heart of the city that was came
out in 2000 somebody who lives on Cape
Cod is a man named David McCullough
well-known for John Adams a lot of other
things and it's the only thing on the
book the only endorsement in the book
back of the book it says sea of glory is
a treasure of a book a spacious sea
story first-rate history and a chronicle
of the length men will go the messes
they can get into in and out of all in
the quest of knowledge it goes on how
did you get his endorsement well we have
a special bond we both went to the same
elementary school in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania
Linden elementary school so and
strangely enough we both ended up living
in Islands off Cape Cod he's on Martha's
Vineyard and so and and he's come to the
island several times to speak in in
support of our local library the
Athenaeum and we got to know each other
where is Cape Cod how big is it how many
people live there well Cape Cod I'm on
nan I'm sorry yeah
Nantucket is about 10,000 year-round no
one's quite sure how many people are
there in the summer it can get close to
70,000 it's about 14 miles long and it's
about 30 miles off Cape Cod and it's
it's kind of schizophrenic living there
I mean that the summer crowds come and
and then in in February in March it's a
very different story but it's it's a
very tight community it was a great
place for us to raise our children we
moved there when our kids were one and
four they're now 19 and 21 and
it it's a place where obviously the sea
is never far away
earlier you talked about William
Reynolds writing a private journal and
you also talked a lot about the public
journals are they required journal write
of all the men explain that yeah well
about a couple weeks into the voyage
Wilkes issued an order that all his
officers had to keep official logs of
the of the voyage and that these logs
had to be turned over to him at the end
of the voyage and needless to say these
would be self censored documents that
since everyone knew they were going to
be turned over to Wilkes at the end so
they some of them are very detailed some
of them are are just perfunctory entries
and but the result is that there a huge
number of journals to draw on when when
working on this there's more than 20 of
them at the National Archives in
Washington and there are other journals
scattered at DePauw repositories all
over the country there's about half a
dozen of the method by Aniki library at
Yale
there's Reynolds journal at Franklin
Marshall and so it gave a vast number of
documents to work with when researching
this book well you constantly talk about
turning points in your book where the
men on these ships were affected by
something that Wilkes wood had done what
what are the major turning point well
you know I think the major turning point
for a lot of these men occurred just off
the coast of Peru about a year into this
voyage as I said earlier they had begun
worshipping Wilkes but Wilkes began to
reveal himself hardly as the friend they
all thought he was he became what he
called the martinet someone who
belittled and mocked the officers that
he initially treated as his friends and
by a year into the voyage the division
line was was very wide and Wilkes had
expected to be get an acting appointment
as Captain and when he left Peru he and
they were setting out into the Pacific
he thought that the chances that they
would run into another US naval vessel
were very slim and he appeared in the
morning of August 1839
on the quarterdeck of the Vincennes
wearing a captain's uniform his officers
were astonished and he said that now
that I am cat the self-appointed captain
of the US exploring expedition I should
be regarded as a Commodore and he had
happened to bring along the blue
swallow-tailed pennant of a naval
Commodore which he ordered to be taken
to the masthead of the Vincennes and
then for the next three years he would
be the self-proclaimed Commodore of the
US exploring expedition and and this was
a galvanizing moment it it showed his
officers that this guy was willing to do
just about anything he wanted to do and
even if they felt it was illegal but for
Wilkes he needed that he needed that to
have that that look that that to be a
Commodore to lead this expedition and
even though it was something he had done
for himself it really energized his
command you say it won't that many
things happen to him at the end of the
whole voyage was that he was what fined
$12,000 for what reason right
well when he was he was fined because he
was legally a lieutenant and he had been
under the impression that he was going
to be enacting a captain and so he had
instructed his men to be paid as a
captain and but when he returned and the
government found out that he had been
paid as a captain even though he was
legally a lieutenant they said he had to
return all the pay that wasn't wasn't
owed him and Wilkes would fight it and
actually win that one and because it was
pretty much acknowledged he did deserve
to be in acting captain how much did the
American people pay attention to this
expedition when it was underway well you
know it was it was they paid some
attention to at the beginning and
particularly after it was announced that
Wilkes had discovered Antarctica
President Martin Van Buren the president
who had sent this expedition out made
this announcement to Congress in the
fall of 1840 and this got some airplay
but unfortunately for Wilkes
van Buren would lose the election and
the Whigs would come in and it would be
president Tyler would be president when
Wilkes returned and as soon as the Whigs
came in they tried to squash all all
publicity for this expedition so that by
the time they returned four years after
leaving the American people were had
been in the dark for several years
really didn't know what was going on and
this really frustrated Wilkes and his
officers because they felt they had led
one of the great greatest expeditions
ever to go out and yet no one knew about
it a couple of times during the in your
book you talk about it being a year and
a half since he had received a letter
from his wife you know and obviously you
think that his wife was very important
the story got one of the yeah portraits
of her here yeah Wilkes it wilks's wife
Jane Renwick was was very important to
him he had for most of his professional
career he had lived and worked with Jane
and it's clear that she may have
scripted some of the moves that got him
this command and he referred to her and
not only as his assistant but as his
moderation he had a fanatical
personality that you know he could push
things too hard and Jane would always
rein him in but when the expedition left
he was without James Jane's hand and and
I think a lot of the problems that
occurred early on in Wilkes his command
was because suddenly he was at without
his moderation without Jane worried he
met her he had they had actually grown
up together in New York
both well-to-do families in New York
City and Wilkes wood was very good
friends throughout his life with Jane's
brother James Renwick who was a
professor at Columbia is this Renwick
Art Gallery here the same name well yeah
the the Renwick who would design the
Smithsonian Institution the castle on
the mall
was was wilks's nephew was James Renwick
son and so yeah they were there was a
lot of they of the same family and so
Jane was so important to Wilkes that
what made it all the tougher was that if
the communication during this expedition
was very difficult they were going to
very far-flung reaches of the world and
it took more than
years from to get mail from a home and
he had had a daughter born just two
weeks before the expedition left you
know he knew she would have no memory of
him and so he was two years without any
kind of information from her and he he
may have come a little unhinged in terms
of his personality and certainly that's
his officer officer's thought so how
many letters remain and have you read
him yeah well one of the great surprises
and joys of researching this at this
book was to discover that in 1978 a
large group of Wilkes Papers was donated
to Duke University and they contained
close to a hundred letters written by
Wilkes to his wife Jane and they really
opened up a whole window into Wilkes his
personality because Wilkes is really an
igneous officers they couldn't figure
out what was going on and these letters
Wilkes tells Jane everything and they
don't always serve his reputation well
but they do give you an indication of
the of the personal sacrifice he really
went through because this was a family
man he had spent most of his
professional life with his wife and kids
working at home and then to be away for
four years to suffer the the deprivation
he went through was was very difficult
and how much did she get involved back
here in Washington on his behalf while
he was away well one of the things
Wilkes hoped for was that even though he
had named himself Commodore he was
hopeful that the administration would
give him the the promotion he wanted
before before that he returned and make
everything right and so as the
expedition was winding down its last
year it was clear that the tiler
administration was not going to give him
the promotion he began to write letters
to to Jane do anything you can to help
me with this promotion and Jane worked
very hard she went all the way to the
president several times the president
told her personally told her clearly
don't come again
you're not helping your husband's cause
and she worked as hard as she could and
the problem was it was just an entirely
different political climate and all
those connections that had served the
Wilkes family so well when the
expeditions set out we're not helping
them on the expeditions return there's a
familiar name that in this book it's a
Christmas
flower plant that it's prominent in this
story wine set yes
the fellow who brought us two points
area yep that's the man you know and
that's amazing thing with this this
story this expedition there's so many
tentacles that go out there points it
was the secretary of the war when it was
clear the Secretary of the Navy and the
Van Buren administration wasn't going to
get this expedition out of the dock
points it was brought in to to get it to
make it happen and the none other than
John Quincy Adams who was then in
Congress went to points it and said all
I want to hear is that the u.s.
exploring expedition has sailed and
within a few months points it would
appoint Wilkes to the command it
outraged the Navy but Wilkes got it
organized and got it out there how is
the flower named after well he points it
was as before there are ambassadors but
he I guess it's counsel to Mexico and it
was there that he brought brought the
flower back that now bears his name what
are the other turning points in the
voyage well the other one of the the the
great turning points is when they do
discover Antarctica and they didn't
technically discover Antarctica because
sealers from Nantucket Stonington
Connecticut and Britain back in the
1820s had had sighted and even ventured
on what we now call the Antarctic
Peninsula below Cape Horn but no one
there was no evidence that what the land
they saw was part of a huge land mass it
would be Wilkes he would be the first
going down from Sydney Australia to to
survey and chart a significant portion
of Antarctica and this was it would be a
true turning point where 1,500 miles of
Antarctica to this day is called Wilkes
land if you look on the globe and and
this was real this is Anna towering
achievement and what would would really
make his men angry and that Wilkes had
pulled it off and yet proud for their
nation
you go into some detail with some
narrative about a lot of the stops along
the way the Hawaii the Fiji Island yeah
Islands and all has this ever been done
before the descriptive nature of it well
you know that there was a the previous
book about the exploring expedition is a
wonderful book by Bill Stanton
written in the 1970s and Bill Stanton is
a historian of science and so that's his
focus mine is of more general interest
and and so I I do focus on the
personalities involved and and so go
into some detail that's not in Stanton's
book and so I think that the two books
balance each other pretty well
so how did when you were describing
ships you know traveling along and
seeing a glacier or a fog and all that
how did you get the narrative in it yeah
well you know one of the things I wanted
to do was to make it come from the
documents themselves because this is so
well documented every officer is keeping
a journal and and and you know I really
wanted to bring to life that in some
cases the sheer terror they were feeling
and and and making this happen it was
really really William Reynolds his
journal that that mae-mae made it real
because Reynolds was was a poet at heart
a great writer and he was it very
interested in what this experience was
doing to him personally and that's an
unusual perspective to get in the 19th
century someone who is not only
describing what he sees but describing
his reaction to what he sees and so it's
with Reynolds voice that I felt like
this is a way to get into the story that
that makes you feel as if you're there
because you not only see it you feel it
you said there are three hundred
forty-six minutes left on the six ships
in 1838 at the beginning forty were lost
at sea or killed and we'll how I asked
you about that in a second and then a
half of the ones that left or on the
ships and they got back is all that
right yeah pretty much
well how many then how many journals
over 500 people were involved in the
whole thing yeah but only the officers
were keeping journals and so there are
about forty officers and you know there
are if you added them all up there about
twenty-five journals
are they most of them are at the
National Archives in Washington how many
of you read
I have Xeroxes of the micro films and I
have been through every one one way or
another I you know one of the challenges
of this was this is a huge this is you
know cast of hundreds scene changes
every three months and I had to focus on
specific personalities if I was going to
render this in a way that you know you
could relate to so that was the
challenge was to to convey that the
scope the grandeur of this expedition
and yet have the focus where you can
have some personal element and so I I
would scan all of these you know but I
would find myself okay this is the day I
need to bring to life and would then go
back and look you know at that specific
date and and really let the narrative
determine in some way where I would go
in terms of the research when did you
start the book when'd you finish I
started the book right after in the
heart of the sea and I finished it
when was that there was about 2000 fall
of 2000 started the research then yes
started the research in fall of 2000 and
and with when I'm working on a book the
research and writing occur simultaneous
getting a sense of where I want to go
with each one and then I I begin to to
write and and that and write and
research and so each and and so that
that then took me another two years so
it's been a solid three years where
would we find you writing and there
explain the circumstances there that
give us the visual account yeah well
once I had assembled all these documents
they are stacked in my basement I have
my work in the basement of my house and
and I've got two rooms one is was
basically all logs and and files and the
other was where I was writing and I
would bring in what I needed for that
specific day and then move it out again
because it just the logistics of all
these logs was very difficult and so I
was working down in the basement of my
house
with my my dog at my feet for a pretty
for a solid two years your tie has
little sailboats on ya I assume that's
done on purpose yes a good friend of
mine Eric Hulk who is a wonderful artist
on Nantucket not only does works of art
but produces ties and so III promised he
might wear this by the way in the middle
of all this have you found another book
that you're working on yeah I'm I'm it's
starting with a voyage but then moving
in slightly different directions and
voyage of the Mayflower and the pilgrims
pilgrims and Indians I'm fascinated with
that what happened there in Plymouth
because it doesn't begin and end with
the Mayflower and Thanksgiving that's
just the beginning and I see it as a
55-year epic really that ends with King
Philip's War and the bloodiest conflict
ever in American history and I think
that's the real story of what happened
in Plymouth what year do you have hope
to have it out we'll see 2006 something
like that by the way is this a full-time
job for you or do you do other things
yeah I'm director of the Eagan institute
of maritime studies but my excellent
staff are the ones that keep things
going on a day to day basis and writing
has become my full-time occupation
another character you write about in the
book is a man named Wilks Henry yes
where did the Wilkes name come from well
this was wilks's Charles Wilkes his
nephew he was a midshipman on this
expedition he was the eldest son of
wilks's widowed sister and Wilkes
brought him along and over the course of
this voyage he became wilks's surrogate
son and they can't became very close and
and it was his different wilks's
difficulties with his officers made this
all the more poignant and it would be in
Fiji where really the cataclysmic
turning point would occur when it came
to Wilkes because Wilkes Henry would be
with another officer negotiating with
Fijian natives for some provisions the
expedition was running out of food as it
was ending a survey of the Fijian
Islands and they were on the island of
Malolo in the western portion of the
Fiji's when through a seer
of tragic misunderstandings fighting
broke out on the beach and Wilkes Henry
and another officer would would die on
the beach in hand-to-hand combat their
brains bashed out with by Fijian war
club and it was impossible for Wilkes
not to take this very personally he
would respond with with absolute force
and massacring the village that he felt
was responsible and Wilkes would be
court-martialed at the end of this
expedition and one of the charges would
be that he had illegally killed the all
these Fijian natives there was a comment
that he made somewhere along the way
about the importance of the white man
yeah well he he was you know this was
typical of the time this the Wilkes
expedition was by no means the first
exploring expedition to run into native
violence James Cook had been killed on a
beach in Hawaii and but once Wilkes had
massacred the natives of the village he
brought those that were remaining
together and and and basically gave them
a sermon on the power of the white man
and that if they ever did anything like
this again he would return
there was somebody picked up on this
voids and they did if I read it
correctly his skull ended up in a jar
some yeah vie dovey was probably the the
most important specimen artifact brought
back by this expedition he was a Fijian
native that several years before the
expedition's arrival in Fiji had killed
a made on a American vessel and he had
and Wilkes abducted him and and instead
of punishing him killing him they're
hanging him there decided to bring him
back to America and show him the power
of America and then return him to Fiji
where he could instruct that his
compatriots on the the power of America
unfortunate Levi Dovie would sicken
towards the end of the voyage died in
New York the very day the expedition
arrived his head would be cut off and
become part of the exploring expeditions
collections where is it it's it ended up
in the Smithsonian Institution along
with all the the 40 tons
specimens and artifacts brought back by
the US exploring it have you seen the
head I have not seen the head there
wasn't it I know there was an attempt to
return the head to Fiji and I'm not
clear exactly where things stand with
that but there I've seen other artifacts
and specimens brought back by the
expedition on both ends of this a name I
forgot to ask you about early Elizabeth
Ann Seton and then on the other end of
it the name James Smithson
which we wound and we want to show some
yeah a video that was taken here in a
moment out at the word Smithsonian keeps
a lot of these artifacts Elizabeth Ann
Seton before I forget it was how did she
play a role she she a wilks's mother
died when he was just 2 years old and he
was put under the care of an aunt who
was with was Seton it was and she would
become after her her time with Wilkes
the infant Wilkes would become a merit
would become Catholic and become
America's first native-born saint and so
Wilkes who would grow up to be you know
this tyrant of a commander had a first
experience with sainthood and the other
end of it the name James Smithson how
did that get in welder Smithson was an
Englishman who died leaving a large
amount of money for a horse it was not
clear exactly what it would be for and
Congress had to figure that out it would
this money would eventually become the
foundation of the Smithsonian
Institution name for Smithson and this
expedition returned to America just as
Congress was grappling with what to do
with the bequest from Smithson and there
was a real battle going on politically
as to you know what it would become
should it become America's national
museum should it become a a library a
research center and the u.s. exploring
expedition would really sort of force
things along because they brought back
more specimens and artifacts and all
three of James Cook's voyages combined I
mean just a huge amount of stuff and
they needed someplace to put it and
there would be annex exhibit in the
Patent Office building but eventually
the Smithsonian Institution would be
founded to house the exploring
expeditions
collection and the amount of stuff they
brought back 40 tons I mean it's just
huge and and much of it is you know no
it is is is it in storage off-site in
the Smithsonian in and and is there
today we're gonna run some video I hope
of what we found some of them your yeah
stuff that they brought back you can see
it there what are we looking at these
are Fijian war club and these are the
throat they would throw these clubs end
over end and that's what would get the
two officers of the u.s. exploring
expedition where is this located at this
is in what they call storage pods the
each these are off-site in the suburbs
outside Washington where the Smithsonian
stores the things that are not on
display and I mean each one of these
pods to me seemed about the size of
Madison Square Garden they're just
cavernous and anthropologist Jane Walsh
gave me a tour of what US exploring
expedition artifacts are there here we
can see there you see Fiji Islands and
those are the original tags from the US
exploring expedition of the artifacts
brought back these are kept in drawers
2p I get to see them not unless you get
the tour no these are these these are
not not anything the general public can
see the Smithsonian did have an X X
exhibit of of the u.s. exploring
expedition back in the 1980s what are we
looking at here these these are
artifacts brought back by the from the
Pacific Northwest wonderfully carved
things from you know what's now
Washington and Oregon State and there
you see made for us
xx that's what the u.s. exploring
expedition was known for short and there
we see Puget Sound 1838 so he and he
explored future yes and it will could
leave more than 300 place names in
Washington state alone out this Major
William rich he was the botanist who was
went with this expedition and so this
this must be something from Polynesia
yeah some of the mats they brought back
there or did they have the room to carry
40 tons of material well they they would
store them in the holds of their ship in
the
olds of the ship and then periodically
send things back if they Jane wall
yeah that's Jane Walsh who was so
helpful to me with this and here here's
some of the cloth brought back from
Polynesia and it's just just fantastic
stuff and and some of it is extremely
rare particularly they got to Fiji at a
time where before a lot of changes came
in and some of the things they brought
back are just better than the things
that they have at Fiji today if you're a
just a citizen can you ask to see this
stuff I'm not sure what the protocol is
and I don't want to get anybody in
trouble there but they these are more
Fijian war club there were different
sizes depending on the type of fighting
they were doing and it's the kind of
club that can cleave a man in half how
much time did you spend looking at this
kind of thing well yeah there's a couple
of stages initially there are there are
some botanical bird skins these kinds of
things that are stored in the actual
Natural History Museum and I did a lot
of that in the beginning and then
towards the end of the book I wanted to
see some of the things I had been
writing about and and and then got the
tour that we're seeing here and it was
very important to really provide a
tactile connection with with what I had
been writing about for all those years
now at the end of this voyage what
happened
well that's a feather blanket that very
rare brought back from in California
well at the end of the voyage what you
know that this should have been met by
the 19th century equivalent of a ticker
tape parade but Wilkes had angered so
many of his officers he had brought
charges against some of his officers who
countered with charges against him that
the summer of 1842 was a series of court
marshals and so instead of celebrating
the the accomplishments of this
expedition
it was wilks's personality that was put
on display everything that went wrong
was was anatomized and and as a result
it became impossible for the American
public to take any pride in this
expedition we really haven't done
justice to Charles Wilkes as personality
as you do in the book
yeah it's hard to do justice well maybe
just one example at the last moment you
say that he he had some of his ships
stopped and do a survey to Rio de
Janeiro
yeah survey well he went on so he could
get all the credit I mean Wilkes was
power-hungry and he wanted fame more
than anything else and and he would just
push it push it push it at the very end
he wanted to be sure he was the first to
arrive in America and he he in his
imagination he he thought there would be
speeches there would be parades there
was nothing of course but so here
absolutely nothing nothing nothing
nothing and just a little story in the
newspaper oh they have arrived and he
immediately went down to Washington to
realize that the the the the tiler
administration was doing everything it
could to bring charges against him to
hush up the the accomplishments of this
extraordinary expedition five courts
Marshall where were they held they were
held on the North Carolina
ship-of-the-line anchored in New York
Harbor and the it was this is part as
Caine Mutiny courtroom drama part Oh Jay
Simpson trial I mean it was all that
summer that all the papers were there
and it was they had a field day looking
at you know all the dirty laundry of the
expedition and they were all tried
together it was one after the other
sequentially and Wilkes requested to be
the last one and so his officers were
tried before him no one knew the the the
pronouncements were not issued until
after well after each trial so everybody
was left in limbo as to what was going
to happen you say William a was tried
because he spoke to Wilkes in an
insulting manner and he was found guilty
what are the circumstances well he had
this is towards the end of the voyage
Wilkes had said all the officers had to
turn over all their their goods may had
a box of artifacts he wanted to take
back with him he and Wilkes got an
argument over it Wilkes said I'm you
know don't speak to me that way I'm
bringing charges against you may with
was found guilty of speaking
disrespectfully to an officer but he all
he got was was really a reprimand Robert
Johnson he was found guilty of
being disrespectful and he would get a
year off but would eventually continue
and have a distinguished naval career
but the doctor the doctor Coolio
he was he was really the linchpin of the
case against Wilkes and in fact the
Secretary of the Navy really encouraged
him to do everything he could he would
be drummed out of the the Corps but
would would get a pardon from Tyler and
would return to the Navy but Robert
Pickering Robert Robert Pickering would
would also heard I'm sorry it's paint me
I'm sorry Robert pink news at Charles
Pickering right Charles Pickering yeah
there's quite a cast of here but no
Pinckney would also would be would be
out for a year but would return to the
Navy said that six charges not properly
following instructions and surveying the
South Shore of is it Upolu Oh blow yeah
hello yeah yeah where's opal oh yeah
this is in Samoa and you know that when
you look at it today these charges were
frivolous I mean it was these were just
one of the aspects of this expedition
was these 340 guys saw way too much of
each other there for four years they
were living together they were working
together they were fighting against each
other and so by the end of it the
charges that they brought against each
other to the to the public seem pretty
frivolous and really were in the
court-martial of Charles Wilkes what
happened well you know it seemed like
they had an open-shut case against him
he had massacred a Fijian village
there's evidence that he lied about the
date that he said he discovered
Antarctica there had been a rival french
expedition and he seemed to revisited
his log and he impersonating an officer
that he was in all these things
Wilkes would get off with a reprimand
basically get off scot-free the only
charge that stuck was that he had
whipped his men too many times 12 lashes
was the legal limit without a
court-martial he had done three
sometimes four times that with with some
of the seamen and that would be the only
charge that would be stick no here's a
picture of him not a drawing
and it looks like he's the rank a little
bit higher than the lieutenant yes he
would he would make it to the rank of
Rear Admiral he would serve in the Civil
War and become the fame he would achieve
would not be attached to the US
exploring expedition it would be
attached to the Trent affair Charles
Wilkes would be the the the officer to
take to Confederate diplomats off a
British vessel the Trent and it would so
infuriating 'land England almost came
into the war on the side of the south
which would not have been good for the
north but Wilkes was crowned a hero when
he returned with the Confederates
diplomats to Boston but to prove that
characters destiny Wilkes would return
as a hero to the Navy quickly get into
trouble with the u.s. naval secretary be
court-martialed and this time the
charges would stick how long did he live
and what did he die of he lived in the
set into this his 70s he would die
quietly at his his home in Lafayette
Square he lived in the Dolly Madison
house and right down here on the right
that's in the water yeah and he by that
time he was working on his autobiography
trying to resurrect the reputation that
he felt had been besmirched unfairly and
and the great irony is in the obituaries
that were written upon his death he was
remembered as the hero of the Trent
affair but no mention made of the u.s.
exploring expert in a body alive today
connected with the family oh yes yeah
I've had emails and talked to and
written to several Wilks descendants a
recent book tour I was on Iran was had
the pleasure of meeting several
descendants of us exploring expedition
officers and and so that's been one of
theirs there's a descendant on Nantucket
even and so the the expedition lives on
a certain few remember it and his first
wife Jane died when of what she died
just really about five years after the
return of the expedition she was
changing trains in New Jersey fell cut
her leg she developed blood poisoning
and would die very suddenly tragically
in Newport Rhode Island and it would
just crush Wilke she was really the love
of his life
and he would eventually remarry and move
into the house in in Lafayette Square
and and all his life when he wasn't
fighting the civil war he would work to
harass Congress to pay for the
publication of the scientific reports
and charts associated with the u.s.
exploring expedition how hard is it
today to find his autobiography it's not
too hard to find it with the the US Navy
published it you can get it through used
books those kinds of things it's it's a
fascinating document it's it's heavy
reading it's it's vast but it but it
tells the story of the world the history
of the world according to Wilkes and you
dedicate this book to my father Thomas
Philbrick and why well he has sort of
been the dissertation adviser I never
had he helped me a lot with this book he
he not only recommend encouraged me to
pursue this topic in fact he had he had
been at Pitt with William Stanton who
had written the previous book about this
expedition and he also transcribed all
of William Reynolds's journal for me my
father did and which is you know two
hundred fifty thousand words
that's quite an undertaking and so that
the two of us are going to to publish in
addition of reynolds journal next year
and and so reason enough to dedicate the
book to him now all these collections
are going to be on the smithsonian
website right while sort of fortuitously
the smithsonian libraries have been
digitizing all of the publication's of
the US exploring expedition and only a
hundred copies of each publication were
ever published by Congress so they're
they're some of the hardest get to get
publications out there and so this is a
real service and so that you're going to
be able to get on the computer and and
look at any page of any one of these
documents some of these are hand-painted
of special pictures of the specimens
brought back they're just beautiful
we only have 15 seconds the big lesson
of the whole story for you was what
character is destiny
our guest is Nathaniel Philbrick and
this is what the book looks like it's
called sea of glory
America's voyage of discovery the u.s.
exploring expedition 1838 to 1842 thank
you very much thank you